this episode is sponsored by tales of
luminaria tales of luminaria is the
latest addition to the tales series
coming straight to your mobile as the
newest real-time action adventure jrpg
if you follow me should know that i'm
already a massive fan of the tales
franchise and i was really happy to see
his spirit successfully transferred to
the mobile platform this is the closest
to a traditional tales game on your
mobile you're gonna get entering a new
world following characters from opposing
nations in a grand story reminiscent of
any big jrpg you have the real-time
combat complete with an art system any
tales fans should be familiar with but
on top of that you have a large party of
playable characters with their own play
style and unique story campaigns to play
through and don't think it's the same
copy and paste campaign either you'll be
running through forests traversing
battlefields trading up your students or
riding monsters depending on whose
campaign you choose and fear not gadget
fans you don't even have to roll for
characters in this game you can just
play through each character's storyline
as and when they are released i repeat
you do not have to roll for characters
so all you need to do is worry about
upgrading their equipment so what are
you waiting for click the link in the
description to download it today and
give it a try now and with that said
let's get on with the video anime fans
are [ __ ] losers
well this video is off to a great start
i'm sure a lot of us weebs who got into
anime and manga at an early age had a
similar experience when they came to our
schools or the kids around us some of us
may have been ridiculed some of us may
have been told to grow up and stop
watching cartoons and some of us may
have just been straight up bullied and
called losers we were outcasts of the
social hierarchy and if i'm being real i
think this is a big reason why power
fantasy stories have seen the monumental
success that they have well you're
telling me this guy can beat up all the
arrogant jocks and get all the chicks
and his secrets opie talent
is being a gamer
it's a shallow reason but it's true we
might not want to admit it but the
viewership and sales numbers don't lie
because we can't seem to stop [ __ ]
reading it basically what i'm trying to
say is it's about time we've got our
spotlight as the most oppressed group in
the world over the current one
gamers the problem is that the landscape
became so saturated with them that it
became impossible to tell good power
fantasy shows from bad pal fantasy shows
because they were all bad when the
industry realized that all it took was
one self-inserted protagonist put in
some generic fancy world surrounded by a
bunch of cardboard cutouts that were
easily mistaken for women they decided
to make a lot
nope keep going
like a little more
there we go time to add these shows to
the list of things i'm gonna watch
before full metal alchemist it got so
bad that even me miss the power fantasy
isekai trash man grant uk got bored of
it that is until i started hearing
whispers of this new web comic called
solo leveling a series that had gained
immense popularity over the past few
years that had put it as the 27th best
manga of all time according to mao the
power fantasy series to end all power
fantasy series and you may be thinking
what revolutionary thing did the series
do that no other series before it had
done to make its claim above all others
is that
is that it i i thought we were building
up to a bigger point solo leveling
originally a korean man were called
you know what i'm not even gonna try
look i already butchered the chinese
words in the link click video and now
you expect me to speak fluent squid game
oh you ever call me there strange gates
to fantasy realms gradually appear
throughout our world containing an array
of powerful monsters and beings around
the same time as this select members of
humanity gained various powers and used
them to combat this ongoing threat these
people became known as hunters and group
themselves in different guilds to team
up to assault these gates killing the
monsters and farming the resources
within like you know an mmo the hero of
our story won seongjin wu is ranked one
of the weakest hunters in all of korea
even referred to wise peers as the
literal weakest hunter in the world
basically just a little baby man little
baby baby baby man little baby
baby man however one day upon his party
entering a high level dungeon by mistake
[ __ ] very much hits the fan as the
monsters within them obliterate their
entire party apart from the little baby
man of course baby man though he does
die he somehow managed to clear a secret
set of trials within the dungeon and
wakes up in a hospital bed after the
incident with a unique ability to
literally be able to level up full-blown
[ __ ] menus and inventory screens in
front of him in the real world gaining
experience and skill trees and all sorts
of bullshits like you know an mmo and so
begins the rise of seong jin woo from
being a little baby man to becoming an
ooh
baby
man
what the [ __ ] am i doing this may sound
very similar to your typical e-cigarette
power fantasy story and if i'm being
real you're absolutely right the series
clearly borrows a lot of elements from
the genre even if it's not technically
isakai but what i think really makes
solo levelling work is that it takes
elements from your typical opi sky power
fantasy and adds an element from your
typical popular shonen anime you know
the other most popular genre in anime
and manga hunters are power ranked from
s to e the main character is an underdog
working his way up the rankings unlike a
lot of power fans see isakai sanjinwu
doesn't instantaneously power up when he
reawakens he is still an e-ranked hunter
he just has the ability to grind his
level up and oh boy does he do some
grinding sanjin wu and only seongjinwu
gets access to these special dungeons
with high level bosses and rare item
drops and of course like any true gamer
you gotta do all the optional side
quests so you're stupidly overpowered
for the final boss you actually get to
see his progression throughout the
series the man is constantly on the
verge of death in these dungeons but he
gets rewarded by the lovely gains the
weapon he acquires and the abilities he
develops i guess you could say he was
levelling up on his own
wait a minute that's not the title what
this means though is that it's just that
much more satisfying when sunjin wu goes
back to the world to take on normal
dungeons look seeing someone almost
[ __ ] die and doing a life or death
optional side dungeon several times
above his level only to go in and breeze
through the main quest area to the
amazement of others struck a chord of me
alright because that's exactly how i
play rpgs too
yes it's a complete wish fulfillment
power fantasy but you know what at least
it felt like he earned it look i'm not
gonna pretend that the world isn't
really stupidly stacked in his favor
though he is the only hunter he was able
to level up or everyone else can only
remain at the power level they were
given when they first became hunters i
repeat he has the ability to power up
while everyone in the world is at a
fixed level cap that's like having the
ability to take a shower when everyone
around you is at an anime convention he
gets so stupid
he gets so stupidly over leveled that he
can outdo anyone in their specialized
role he's a mage fighter tank assassin
healer combo so he's basically just as
toxic as season 10 orn from league of
legends but that's not even his main
ability eventually he gains the ability
to summon shadows from any monster he
kills essentially becoming a one-man
army like what the [ __ ]
but it works because the world itself is
set up for his success the world is a
mishmash of sword art online darker than
black and one punch man what i like is
how modern society is built around the
existence of hunters you're not just
limited to one country a nation's entire
strength is built around the strength of
their hunters as ranked hunters are a
precious resource that can dictate a
country's military and political
strength sanjin wu's rise isn't just
something that affects the hunter's
world it's one that ripples throughout
the entire world and affects the
geopolitical landscape and this
just gives him more [ __ ] moments to
be badass i don't know what to say what
i love about solo leveling is that it
knows what it wants to be and gives you
that on steroids it ups the ante to a
global scale you've got teams from korea
japan china and of course america who
are depicted as
exactly how you think koreans would
depict americans
and i think one major aspect that can't
be ignored is that the art is [ __ ]
outstanding you hear stories of mangakas
working themselves to death doing weekly
manga chapters so i don't know what kind
of [ __ ] black magic the webcomic
industry has cast to allow us to enjoy
full colored weekly chapters that look
like this i mean just look at this this
puts most manga to shame but beyond that
he also uses its medium to its full
advantage webcomics as opposed to manga
are not separated via pages it's a
medium designed to be viewed on the
phone that allows you to endlessly
scroll down almost like it's one
continuous image and what this means is
that some of the most impressive moments
are accentuated by these panels that
seemingly never end an epic depiction of
a battlefield or action that flows
seamlessly as you scroll down in a way
that you just can't do with manga
constrained by a two-page spread it can
make the action easier to follow or the
scale of the battle seems so much more
grand i read all of solo levelling in a
day it's one of those series that was
infinitely bingeable because after
saying all this i think i'm missing the
biggest thing that contributes to this
man was success which is
nothing you know as i was writing this
video i've really tried to rack my brain
as to why solo leveling was so [ __ ]
fun and such a huge success that way i
could end this video off with some cool
introspective moment that really nails
down what makes this series so special
above all its competition but then i
realized what it really does best is
absolutely nothing new so instead i'm
going to talk about kitchen nightmares i
[ __ ] love kitchen nightmares and i
don't know a single person who doesn't
it's one of those shows where if it
comes on or i see someone watching it no
matter what i'm doing i'm just like yeah
i got time to watch and if you've never
seen a single episode before let me
break it down for you we open up to a
struggling restaurant with a cocky owner
who's just like i have the greatest
restaurant in the world the food is
perfect and that's why the restaurant is
putting me in ninety thousand dollars of
debt in comes gordon ramsay big dick
energy orders everything on the menu
chef gets the order and it's like i'm
gonna cook jeff ramsey i'll signature
dish my
my
microwaved chicken baby so of course
gordon takes one bite of the chicken
calls the waitress over and is like this
chicken is rawer than my dick after
this chicken is raw than my dick one day
after no not november so he goes to the
kitchen it's like oi how are you cooking
your food we're the microwave chef with
a microwave are you out your goddamn
mind
if you know chef ramsay is coming
why would you not cook your food on the
day
it blows my mind so of course gordon has
this inspirational talk that turns
everything around that's like all right
shut it i'm about to blow your mind
what if
you cook the food
without a microwave
[Music]
so the lunches fresh ingredients and
everyone that's happily ever after i
swear i just don't google it because
restaurants still probably out of
business and that's kitchen nightmares
oh that was awful i had way too much fun
recording that my point is is that i
know exactly what i'm getting into
basically every episode has an identical
repeatable formula but i don't care
because it's so god damn entertaining
and if a clip appears in my timeline
that shows me that the food is not
busting you bet your ass i'm gonna click
on it to see if the food's not busting
this is how i feel with isakai and a lot
of power fantasy shows at this point
it's kind of just become my comfort
foods because when i look at solo
leveling there is not a lot different to
what we usually complain about i've seen
a load of comments referring to sunjin
woo being like haha this is how kirito
is done right and i'm just like wait
what the man is even more perfect and
flawless than kirito ever was i mean the
guy's functionally in
god i wish i could go from this to this
man went from ricegum to full on k-pop
in the span of about five chapters he
literally looks like the
eighth member of bts
so yeah of course kirito is going to
lose when he's up against the literal
unbeatable army sung jin wu has behind
him
k-pop stand only recently has enemies
been introduced to actually pose a real
threat because before that pretty much
every story arc plays out the exact same
way the [ __ ] is almost everything
everyone shits on a show like sword art
online for but for some reason whenever
my brain was like man you know what the
story is getting kind of repetitive
sunjin wu would show up and be like
arise and then the shadows would be like
and then his eyes would do the glowy
thing and then it would just start
kicking ass and then everyone else would
be like isn't he right to be in here
ranked hunter and then my brain would be
like oh man that was so cool what was i
talking about again it really is just
the rule of cool on crack its biggest
strength is that it does nothing new but
what it does do is done in the best
possible way you can hope for if you
have no interest in these epic pal
fantasy shows then this isn't going to
change your mind about them at all but
if there's just a small part of you that
craves that op protagonist beatdown this
is about as good as the genre can get it
just works for the medium it's in and
for anyone who's like oh man i can't
wait for the anime adaptation i have two
words for you
cg shadows
solo leveling nope i'm gonna let that
one sink in for a little longer
solo leveling is not the 27th best manga
of all time it's not even close but very
few other webcomics get my adrenaline
pumping quite like solo leveling does
this is power fantasy at its finest
which is perfect for isekai power
fantasy trash like me and even though it
does fall victim to pretty much
everything we complain about when it
comes to those generic power fantasy
stories predictable and all it is your
definition of turn your brain off fun
basically what it boils down to is sword
art online
the cooler sword art online that's what
i call a baby man
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you again to tales of luminaria
thanks again to tales of luminaria for
sponsoring me today and also thank you
very much to alpha sigma basil
dysfunctional degenerate elephant ivito
jeff lovatos manopla payne patchett pony
stark walto and everyone else my patreon
for helping to support me for this month
i know i'm a bit behind on hangouts guys
please don't kill me so yes i'm now
setting up in my new place please ignore
the background it is a work in progress
but hopefully this means i have a more
stable working environment at home
rather than going to the office every
day
like a normal person so once i get
everything set up i'll not only keep
doing the videos i'm doing but hopefully
you guys should get more streams as well
that's the plan
don't hold me on that too strictly
anyway that's it from me today no
further updates i've been giggup and
i'll see you all next time